大家好 我是Ceo
我們現在在解放村開車
像我自己個人因為很喜歡跑咖啡廳喝咖啡這樣
然後我喜歡有景色的地方
然後因為解放村是在一個比較高的山上
所以我們看出去的時候就基本上全部都是景物
我們要從聖水轉到解放村要搭兩班公車
所以現在正在等車
那等公車的時間呢來介紹一下今天的OOTD
今天的OOTD呢就是外面一件牛仔外套
然後其實衣服基本上已經要穿過了
可是每天還是有點不同的搭配
然後一件黑色襯衫
然後裡面一件粉色襯衫
就是買的
我覺得它就是一個
非常舒服非常適合就是夏天天氣的褲子
我買了兩件吧
因為跳舞也可以穿
教課也可以穿
然後日常穿都OK的程度
安山塔到了
現在要來點餐了
Ice Americano的漢醬意粉
然後
請給我一點阿芒茲曲奇
早上起來沒有黑咖啡真的是不行
這裡呢就是黑棒村
以前的這一間咖啡廳呢
我非常的喜歡
因為這一間呢還有樓梯
天氣超好的話還可以看得到夕陽
之外呢有一些文青小店
剛剛這邊就有衣服店啊
有些咖啡廳我知道
但是我還沒有來過
本意外經過了愛情什麼翻譯的拍攝景點
喔原來他們是在這裡吃飯的啊
Seasonal Table
要記住這間店喔 下次來吧
這間店我也是第一次來
之前好像開滿久的
但我每次都是經過 然後沒有來過
我好像是第一次在韓國吃泰式的感覺
等一下來吃吃看
牛肉河粉的概念
看起來很好吃耶 很香耶
這看起來超厲害的耶
我最喜歡Ojingo了
大概就是Olive Young旁邊呢
有一間Rendez-Vous
買了一個就是
其實最近Arnois真的非常的紅
然後這個呢是PDRN的噴霧
我找它其實找滿久的
因為一般Olive Young其實沒有賣這種小噴霧
它的質地呢就是非常的細緻
搖一搖
就是非常的方便
然後又可以滿保濕的這樣什麼
因為其實我真的來Olive Young太多次了
所以其實我對Olive Young的東西
某種程度來說還滿熟的
這個是我這趟買的新東西
原本沒有
然後其實它因為它是惠利代言的
所以就是因為它是惠利代言的
所以我才就想說
欸有興趣喔
好像可以買一下
然後剛剛好呢
我的就是卸妝已經要用完了
所以我就試著看看
想說欸那用用看新的牌子
結果它的卸妝油超讚的欸
它的卸妝油是那種
就是超級不油的卸妝油
就是然後我朋友就跟我說
好的卸妝油通常都不會油
因為我是一個非常容易長痘痘的人
所以我覺得
就是如果卸妝油太油的話
我就不行
但是這個卸妝油超清爽
然後重點是它的
就是卸妝有清爽就算囉
它的洗面乳洗完
對毛孔超級乾淨
惠麗代言的好
真的是不錯
我剛剛去買了一個PDRN的
如果你有看我
可能maybe前幾天的影片的話
你會看得到
其實就是一個保養品
但是它是在臉上妝之前
然後使用的保養品
然後拍一拍
它很像洗面乳
然後當它就是上上去之後
然後你的臉就會變得
保濕度非常高
然後妝會變得非常的服貼
其實我今天有用
剛剛買了這個
這個我其實用過非常多個
就是因為我太容易長痘痘了
痘痘貼裡面有偽針的痘痘貼
帶回台灣 然後存貨這樣
剛看起來好像
就是我不知道它有沒有名
但是就是我剛剛看它是可以就是整理頭髮用的
然後我剛剛頭髮有稍微的整理一下
然後我就發現說它比較不會那麼的毛躁
我覺得滿好的
想說如果我那麼常來整理頭髮
然後不想要讓它看起來毛毛躁躁
因為我自然捲
所以就覺得這個好像蠻值得買的
剛剛現場試用了一下
哈囉
安安
我們人生的朋友有
要去逛一個
迎接新朋友之後要去帶她去逛的第一間店
很久沒來韓國了嗎
十年了
等一下再看要吃什麼
她說不要吃身上會太臭的東西
我蠻喜歡的店
那天剛好路過沒有逛到
有我的帽子
這鞋子超可愛的
我有這一頂
對啊 他們好像上一季就是做了一個
鞋子都是跟Henry Bear
喔 真的喔
這樣還可以
韓妞
還行耶
這個顏色很可愛
這顏色很可愛耶
我們姊姊買了新的帽子
喔 這個顏色好可愛喔
這個購物袋
我們晚餐的行程呢
又來吃馬鈴薯湯了
這間我已經吃過N百次了吧
中國人 本地人
或者是觀光客都會來的地方
看起來好好吃喔
有杜拜巧克力耶
我的是杜拜巧克力
YA
吃吃看
真的好吃
然後我們剛剛買了什麼呢?
Artiste跟Burrish的內衣
然後跟Low Classic的帽子
我們明天繼續
就明天見啦 掰掰